we found this video this is from 10
years ago we're going to split it into
two parts for you ten years ago 2013.
listen to Don Lemon talking about five
things that could fix the black
community and tell me if this sounds
like uh Don Lemon in 2023 or did
something happen to him over the course
of these last 10 years because black
people if you really want to fix the
problem here's just five things that you
should think about doing here's number
five and if if this doesn't apply to you
if you're not doing this then it doesn't
apply to you I'm not talking about you
here's number five pull up your pants
walking around with your ass and your
underwear showing is not okay in fact it
comes from prison when they take away
belts from The Prisoner so that they
can't make a weapon and then it evolved
into which role a prisoner would have
during male on male Prison Sex the one
with the really low pants is a
submissive one you get my point
number four now is the n-word
by promoting the use of that word when
it's not germane to the conversation
have you ever considered that you may
just be perpetuating The Stereotype the
master intended acting like
now number three respect where you live
start small by not dropping trash
littering in your own communities I've
lived in several predominantly white
neighborhoods in my life I rarely if
ever witness people littering I live in
Harlem now it's an historically black
neighborhood every single day I see
adults and children dropping their trash
on the ground when a garbage can is just
feet away
just being honest here hey I'm a lemon
out there sounded like Larry Elder and
Thomas Soul what but that's lemon 10
years ago so uh pick up your pants first
off I did not know about that uh
situation in the men's prisons I watch
Orange is the New Black that was a
woman's prison
they're up to some scary stuff over
there I did not know the other thing uh
but anyway pick up your pants okay this
sounds like Jordan Peter Peterson stuff
right wear clothes that fit shocking say
the n-word a little bit less okay I
think we can all get on board that one
uh respect where you live and lemon
makes a point of saying he's lived
around a lot of white people my God is
there anyone more assimilated living
with black people and white people
living together cats and dogs it's crazy
he continued
number two finish school you want to
break the cycle of poverty stop telling
kids are acting white because they go to
school or they speak proper English a
high school dropout makes on average
nineteen thousand dollars a year a heist
a high school graduate makes twenty
eight thousand dollars a year a college
graduate makes fifty one thousand
dollars a year over the course of a
career a college grad will make nearly a
million dollars more than a high school
graduate that's a lot of money
and number one and probably the most
important just because you can have a
baby it doesn't mean you should
especially without planning for one or
getting married first more than 72
percent of children in the
African-American Community are born out
of wedlock that means absent fathers and
the studies show that lack of a male
role model is an Express train right to
prison and the cycle continues I think
you guys see what I'm trying to do here
the guy was saying now I don't know how
that is considered journalism that's his
opinion on all of those things but that
used to be something that could air on
CNN
foreign
[Music]